We're told that Naomi
lives at 2nd Avenue and 3rd
Street representing 2,
3 on the graph below.
Her school is it 4th
Avenue and 10th street,
representing 4, 10 on the graph.
She walks over to 4th Avenue
and up to 10th Street.
Plot her home and
school on the map.
How many blocks does
Naomi walk to school?
So let's plot her home first,
2nd Avenue and 3rd Street,
which they are giving
us the coordinates 2, 3.
So the x-axis right
over here, this
is representing the avenues.
And then the y-axis,
or the vertical axis,
this represents the street.
So 2, 3.
So this right over here is
2nd Avenue and 3rd Street.
So you see here, we
went to 2nd Avenue
and then we went
up to 3rd Street.
This is where she lives at home.
We could have also said
3rd Street and 2nd Avenue.
Now her school is a 4th
Avenue and 10th street.
And now we're going to go,
so if we start at the origin,
we go to 4th Avenue and then
go up 10 to 10th Street.
So this is the coordinate 4, 10.
So this is where our home is.
This is where a school is.
They say she walks over to 4th
Avenue and up to 10th Street.
So she walks from 2nd
Avenue to 4th Avenue
and then up to 10th Street.
How many blocks does
Naomi walk to school?
Well as she walks from
2nd Avenue to 4th Avenue,
she's going to walk 2 blocks.
1 block and 2 blocks.
You shouldn't get confused by
they're actually marking off
with these lines
every half a block.
So that's 1 block to 3rd
Avenue, 2 blocks to 4th Avenue.
So that's 2 blocks so far.
And then she goes from
3rd Street to 10th Street.
Well, if you go from 3rd
Street to 10th Street,
that's going to
be 7 more blocks.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So 2 in the horizontal
direction and then 7
in the vertical direction.
So that's 9 total blocks.